what were the some of the stories of
where your head was during the making of
this movie
we were chasing several things we were
chasing the right kind of weather we
were chasing department stores that had
not been altered to the point of
dropping the ceilings and having air
conditioning installed which meant that
you didn't have the height to build the
Santa Mountain Inn and we were also
looking for that old timey feel with
light fixtures and everything our budget
did not extend to building anything like
that and it so happened that great
location scouting in Cleveland was able
to find us the house and the department
store in the same town and that meant
that was an anchor for the for the
production so we were able to shoot in
the cold weather in Higbee's department
store in the outside the setting up of
the parade and the subsequent interior
of the the department store happened in
January I think it was January 4th or
5th it was when the department store was
closed over a Sunday they agreed to
allow us in there to prep film and then
strike all of those sets so it was I
think I remember staying up for three
days straight with the with the parade
and with the interior of the store but
Cleveland gave us everything that we
needed there what part of this movie
gave you that kept you up the most at
night was it the parade scene or what
was the design element of this that you
were the most worried about or was it
just one day after another of challenges
I would say it was all pretty high level
challenge I didn't find any of it easy
and especially towards the end when we
were trying to build these massive sets
that weren't finally kept in the movie
we had a rooftop of the entire
working-class section of Cleveland with
complete with Russian style Orthodox
churches in the background on a on a
diorama
we had reindeer we had Santa's elves we
had Ming the Merciless and the planet
[ __ ] we had all of these things and
they were all crammed into a space of
about a week at the end of the shooting
period and I think that was that really
tested me to my limits